[Music]
hello there there is well over 1 000
skins in fortnite and at some point we
all choose a favorite from kittens
riding human-shaped robots to the cast
of street fighter party hipping their
way onto the island fortnite somehow has
found a way to make everything fit but
let's be honest how many of these skins
are important to the storyline of
fortnite today we find out who is key to
the narrative please use the comments
below to list your choices and let's
find out the 15 most important
characters in the fortnite storyline so
far that is oh obligatory code adamaru
begging here cheers
at number 15 we have drift a graffiti
artist with a secret drift first
appeared on the fortnite island all the
way back in chapter one season five days
before this rift started appearing
around the island and in the real world
too and drift was dragged through one of
those in terms of law drift is the first
person we know of to travel from our
reality here on earth to the multiverse
of fortnite back in 2018 the reality
tears saw the der burger head from in
game all the way to the california
desert and that's where drift vanished
after tagging the mascot since then
drift mask and outfit have evolved and
they've been linked to a mysterious
group known as the fox clan after three
years they attempted to contact him but
to this day drift still remains a figure
of intrigue are the foxclan important in
this story or not make your mind up
fortnite
[Music]
at 14 we have a pop star ariana grande i
know some people will get a little upset
that non-fortnite characters are part of
the law but in this case it's true
ariana was here to sing to us fly about
in the clouds a little and hit us with
an oversized hammer it was all for fun
and for 10 minutes of music for the rift
what many people don't know is that the
rift tour is officially fortnite law
it's part of the story the event was
actually a ruse by the alien invaders of
season seven the last reality staged
this event to scan our brains
this is official by the way completely
real and told to us by the mustard we
call donald who is responsible for the
decisions around the story of fortnite
while you were jumping around on the
back of a cuddle team leader the aliens
were reading your memories it looks like
they were searching for something
scanning all the events we've lived
through in the past maybe they were
looking for a weakness maybe an answer
to the question we don't know yet maybe
it's all about the zero point like
everything else what we do know right
now is that ariana's performance is now
fortnite canon she was the one who sold
us out to the aliens
at 13 on the list of important
characters in fortnite is raz during
season six the island was thrown through
reality blooms and part of the map was
sent all the way back to the primal age
a giant spire arose and one man was
besotted by that thing over the season
razz was revealed to be in possession of
a shard of energy with runes upon it we
all associate with kevin the cube he
also owned numerous room scrolls one of
them actually needed lupus sacrifices to
power up razzi's obsession with the
spire caused him to become corrupted
thanks to that spire artifact he carries
all his meddling with the runic language
and those artifacts caused the last
reality to notice the island and invade
us
so without raz and his obsession the
mother ship would never have come here
so it isn't ariana's fault it's razzy's
fault let's blame him
[Music]
number 12 and 11 are the ice king and
the prisoner remember these guys back in
chapter one we had really random events
which didn't seem to have a reason like
the ice king who arrived on a floating
block of ice to wake up live in a ball
for a few days and then turn everything
into snow so random yet this action
impacts the story more than we realized
season seven was a tale of fire and ice
the block of ice which housed polar peak
was slowly melting revealing a prisoner
locked away thawing out after he escaped
he was revealed to be some sort of deity
with the power of elemental fire and
then created a volcano at the opposite
side of the island to the ice biome the
ice king's attempt to freeze the entire
island was in vain and as the sun came
out and warmed up the entire island
these two battling gods had eventually
set something free which would change
the storyline of fortnite forever a
final blast from the volcano hit the icy
mountain revealing something inside a
beast like no other a guide you a
devourer was awoken
sensing the power of the zero point it
rushed in to claim it and we all know
how that ended but would it have
happened without the ice king and the
prisoner waging war on each other
let's continue with this story beat with
number 10 on the list of most important
characters singularity when the fires
burnt the island to a crisp we jumped
forward in time the future arrived and
everything had changed tilted towers
became neo-tilted retail row had a
futuristic mega complex built upon it
and the volcano became the home of a
giant mech this was the season of
singularity we had seen her briefly in
the past with her helmet in the vault
but now she was not hiding anymore
singularity erected a statue of herself
very arrogant of you it was unclear why
the mech was being built but fortnite
did heavily insinuate that singularity
was the driving force behind it she
watched the building loading screens and
unlocked styles which linked to each
part of the mech's built then it all
became clear the day the devourer came
for the zero point singularity's mech
saved us all that day and prevented the
collapse of reality her statue ended up
being a sword designed to kill this
beast and upon besting the devourer the
mech flew into space never to be seen
again
was singularity on board where did it
actually go and why did it leave the
zero point in ruin i think singularity
knows the answers and according to the
mustard we call donald again singularity
is only one of her names she's coming
back to the story as another character i
can't wait to see who that is
[Music]
to number nine and enter the cube queen
the queen is the most recent character
to hit the fortnite storyline following
on from the attack of the last reality
and the mothership above us we finally
were able to see the woman who wants to
run reality the first thing we ever saw
her do was crush a rift butterfly we're
incredibly early on in seeing her effect
on the storyline so that's why she's
only at number nine as of right now she
just sort of sits in a bubble
contemplating the future cubetown is
building around her and whatever she's
planning is happening real soon i'm sure
the next time we make this list the cube
queen will be higher but right now she's
just sitting there so she's staying at
number nine come on do something
in at number eight is a double character
it's batman and batman let me explain
dc's impact on the fortnite narrative
can't be ignored one man in particular
has made more advances in the story than
any other batman the problem is there's
two of them when the batman fortnite
zero point series began bruce wayne was
drop kicked into a rift in gotham city
and ended up on our lovely island he
soon completely lost all his memories he
quickly realized though that you don't
need memories because emotions carry
over between loops so feelings are
important my mum was right all along the
world's greatest detective used etchings
on his suit to give himself clues at the
end of each loop coordinates advice and
other vital information without his
memory mr wayne was able to recruit
catwoman find a way out of the loop and
find a way back to gotham insane
abilities batman showed us that being
the final player alive in the final
storm circle would result in breaking
the loop and thus escaping the storm
impressive feat yeah but that wasn't all
he did batman found a way into the
bunkers we'd been staring at for years
and from there found the pure portal to
send everyone back home except eternal
voyager but let's not talk about him
batman then teamed up with the
foundation to foil lex luthor's plan to
get onto the island he's impacted the
lore of the story like no one else
but there is another batman this one is
a blend of the joker and bruce wayne
known as the batman who laughs without a
doubt this version of batman is a bad
guy and was actually responsible for
sending the other batman onto the island
his ultimate goal was to get there
himself and that was achieved one week
ago he's like a sleeper agent on the
island right now living through
countless loops but this guy has some
top quality plot armor you should know
about the visor he wears is made from
dark matter and this stuff is so mighty
the power of the island has no effect on
him the batman who laughs retains all
his memories his powers and his ability
to speak this madman is currently
setting up a future storyline in which
the batman who laughs visits all the
other universes through the pure portal
and corrupts them all one by one we're
currently waiting for the next comic
book to release to see what he's gonna
do next i'll be sure to keep you up to
date so you should totally press
subscribe right now did that work yay
subscribers
at number seven is the scientist the
thickest member of the seven during the
greatest season in fortnite history aka
season x season x is here and the world
is destabilizing fast ah good memories
season x celebrated the entire first
fortnight chapter and brought back
reimagined elements from the previous
two years this led to another meteor
hitting the island but unlike last time
it was suspended above the ground this
time the visitor inside was none other
than the scientist another member of the
seven over the ten weeks the scientist
told us much more about the loop thanks
to tapes on the island even now a few
years later much of it is still cryptic
the zero point must be contained once
more the event at the end of the season
saw seven realities collide as the
rocket hit the zero point seemingly
destroying it forever we were all sucked
into a black hole and fortnight ended
for a few days
then everything rebooted and the loop
reactivated if the scientist had tried
to stop the loop he had failed and all
his efforts were in vain but he did gift
us with a brand new map so he deserved
to be high on this list and it would be
a full year until another member of the
seven came to the island
up to number six on the list of the most
important characters in fortnite and
this one is popular midas
one of the most unique characters to
ever grace the island who was revealed
back in season 2 of chapter 2 a bond
style villain with the ability to change
objects into gold by simply touching
them the season saw midas and his
minions choose between ghost and shadow
with all the options changing the map
forever but this was all subterfuge
midas had a secret plan that season he
was building a device once we unlocked
his floor of the facility we watched him
advance building something around the
zero point deep underground
meanwhile he was also collecting masks
as if they were trophies since that day
we've learned that wearing a
self-contained suit is a great way to
nullify the island's effects which could
explain why we saw the cyclo suit found
in midas chambers days before he
switched the device on the event was
impressive midas attempted to push back
the storm it looked to have failed by
the end but it did allow us to briefly
leave the loop and visit another world
this was the first time we saw io the
imagined order the first time agent
jones saw us but alas moments later we
were dragged back into the loop what
midas did that day was the start of the
i o storyline and right now crew members
are receiving midas sidekicks with the
promise of more lore and backstory
coming soon midas is a complicated
character with links to chaos agent
ghost and shadow and he has a daughter
too jules so the story of midas and his
impact on fortnite is only just
beginning and i can't wait to see what
happens next
[Music]
we're in the top five if you haven't yet
make sure you put your top five in the
comments below let's see how close they
all are when the marvel season arrived
not many of us expected it to impact the
story well it certainly did from thor's
awesome dialogue indeed to captain
america's ability to lift meow meow and
of course groots but
wow one character did something above
and beyond all the others that man is
tony stark iron man season 4 of chapter
2 saw galactus the devourer of worlds
looking to feast on a planet when that
huge guy felt the power of the zero
point he raced here to consume it
because he hungers
thor was able to get to the island quick
enough to use the bifrost to call the
avengers to save this island iron man in
his lovely airtight suit went straight
to work this man is legendary in a few
short weeks tony was able to understand
rift technology and teleported a part of
new york to the island this gave him all
the tech he needed to fight galactus
stark made a few billion battle bus
clones and armed them with nuclear bombs
he then sent us straight in the face of
galactus iron man told us that this
would cause a rift to take the big man
away and he was completely right iron
man saved the zero point from being
eaten he saved our reality and so next
time you thank the bus driver remember
what iron man did for us and the story
at number four please welcome dr sloan
sloan has been on the island for two
consecutive seasons now a mastermind and
a high ranking member of the imagined
order dr sloan puts duty before
friendship and is seen by many as the
real villain of chapter two sloane was
first heard when sending an io agent
onto the island to protect the zero
point
when that failed she came to the island
herself to lead the fight against the
alien invasion sloan has actually tried
to kill us in the past which isn't very
nice first recruiting us to make a
daring attack on the mothership and then
refusing to bring us back home leaving
us to go kaboom luckily we survived our
fall from the edge of space and sloan
had already continued with her plan
opening the redacted bunker for some
reason away from the island sloan has
made an alliance with lex luthor and the
batman who laughs to create alternative
doors to the island and the pure portal
which lives there without a doubt sloane
is up to something but we have to wait
to see what her next move will be and
what about those images in her office
sloane knows more than we probably ever
will her next step will likely come
during the end of season event as the
cube queen makes her advances
[Music]
into the top three we go and it's time
for a character who is the bedrock of
the story the foundation when the
foundation arrived on the island it was
immediately obvious he wasn't a newcomer
here he recognized an i o agent
immediately and started to break his
face foundation likes to scrap in his
two appearances so far he's fought agent
jones he's fought the batman who laughs
he's fought lex luthor and he's even
fought the og batman himself he loves a
good scuffle foundation was revealed to
be the leader of the seven a group
responsible for the black hole event in
chapter one which made so many kids cry
their mission statement is to liberate
the zero point and destroy the loop
forever the foundation seems to be one
of the oldest characters in fortnite
history he knows everything about
everything he once told batman about the
dawn of time and the big bang which
formed the zero point and the omniverse
foundation has already made a pivotal
sacrifice to the story by giving up his
life to protect the collapse of the zero
point locking himself in the spire
thankfully that was short-lived and he
was transported to gotham city and by
the end of that story the foundation
gave us lots of information he told us
about self-contained suits like those
used by the seven and how they are able
to stop the effects of the island with a
suit like this the user would not lose
their memories their voice or their
superpowers right now the foundation has
found himself back on the island and
he's already escaped the loop by being
the last survivor in the final circle
he's currently around he's searching for
the imagined order
[Music]
at second spot on the list is agent
jones chapter two had a few questionable
story beats early on but once we met
agent jones the storyline became clear
jones was revealed to be an agent of io
the imagined order watching us and
controlling the loop under the
leadership of dr sloan agent jones would
frequently jump onto the island to fix
research or change something before
returning home again this led to so so
many drone snapshots on the island it
was impossible to finish a game without
seeing a jones clone the importance of
agent jones came to a head during the
latter stages of chapter 2 season 5 when
the zero point he was fighting so hard
to protect was moments away from
disaster feeling helpless agent jones
made a last-ditch attempt to save
reality and brought us that member of
the seven we just talked about the
foundation jones completely betrayed his
superiors he left io to save the zero
point and made another sacrifice moments
later agent jones used his only way to
escape the island the portal device to
cocoon the zero point with a foundation
inside this means agent jones is trapped
in the loop and he must have lost his
memory by now he was last spotted hiding
as a cow
what a fall from grace hopefully the
foundation will find him again and the
next part of the story can begin
[Music]
and here we go my pick for the most
important character in fortnite history
the visitor unlike all the other
characters and skins on this list he
can't be found in any cinematic trailers
his impact is never seen and heck we
never saw him once on the island but
without the visitor the story of
fortnite would not be here back in
chapter one during season four and the
booming popularity fortnite found a
secret unlockable skin was added the
blockbuster over weeks we pieced
together the story of the visitor the
meteor in the sky which started this
whole story had the visitor inside after
breaking three he found his way to the
rocket layer on the mountains and began
an escape plan oh here's something that
most people don't notice the visitor can
actually be seen calibrating the rocket
in this loading screen look there's his
shadow when the rocket was ready and the
day came we were all clueless what the
hell was happening we all presumed it
was a malfunction later it was confirmed
he was attempting to find the zero point
something which the scientists managed
to find a few seasons later so much has
happened since that very first time the
seven arrived and the rocket event
confused us all so many questions remain
unanswered but for certain the story of
fortnite is all down to the day the
visitor came to the island in 2018. so
therefore i believe the most important
character in fortnite history is the
visitor what say you so that's my list
of the top 15 what do you reckon you can
be honest is your order different do you
have different characters on it i'll be
in the comments to see what you think
huge thank you to those who've used my
code to adamaru over the last fortnight
it's very much appreciated thank you
very much i'm adam you're awesome i'll
see you next time